so one of my absolute favorite games
this year is an odd one for me because
I'm not normally a huge shooter guy but
that has to go to titanfall what again
an amazing game purely because it's the
most accessible shooter that I played in
some time call of duty is great and
don't get me wrong I'm sure they're
plenty of people out there that are
amazing at call of duty have all the
twitch skills required in order to be
good at it but I don't you know I'd have
a time to put into playing that game but
time for you can jump straight in you
can jump into a game with the sort of be
the automatic pistol and it's just so
much fun like going around doing the
stealth thing sneaking up behind people
with a smart pistol shooting them with
that super cool and then there are giant
robots and you get stomp around in giant
robots and fire rockets of people which
is just wrecking ball awesome so time
for just all round really great fun and
I'm still playing it to this day on PC
and I think that's testament to how
great that gamers so controversial
choice but it's a mobile game and it's
gotta go two threes threes is pretty
much up there as one of the greatest
ideas of all time ok it's up there with
Tetris this game every day on the way to
work and on the way back I will play
threes if I'm in a doctor's waiting room
I will play threes if I am in line at
the post office I will play threes it is
just fantastic I don't know how to
describe why it's a fantastic to you
other than it's just so you can't stop
you just keep swiping it's a really
simple concept of adding up numbers and
trying to basically put certain ones
together and it's got really cute little
animations in it it's really simple and
honestly I just it's just brilliant
so GTA 5 I know this came out last year
but having played it on ps4 it is a
completely different experience and
reviewing that game this year was just
an amazing opportunity for me to place
her it again and in first-person mode
it's just a brilliant brilliant thing I
think playing it in the third person was
great but it's changed the game for me
it's like if they don't offer first
person in the future grand theft autos I
will be shocked because playing it first
person just makes the whole thing feel
more alive it makes you feel much more
in the game than it did in 3rd person
you know your actions feel you consider
your actions more you want to study the
environment more and the fact is that
the world that rockstar is created is
just no one else has created an open
world like rockstar and in first person
you really really want to explore it
what a fantastic game if you haven't
played it yet I thoroughly recommend
going out alone getting it on ps4 or
holding out until the pc version comes
out in the new year when hopefully we'll
get mods Bayonetta 2 now this is a game
that i gave a 10 out of 10 too and it
was actually the first ten gamespot
given for about four years which I'm
really quite a big deal for us like as
an editorial group Bayonetta 2 is pretty
much the perfect actually I can't think
of any other games that mechanics it has
but just so well done every action that
you take with the triggers when you do
which time when you do the combos it's
just perfect but i can't i can't tell
you I know haiti's were a perfect for a
game but it's just nails it like the the
tightness of the controls the action
that's on the screen you know there is
so much going on in that game when
you're in a battle and yet you know what
to do you know you never get lost in it
and that's an amazing achievement not to
mention that it is completely nuts like
this start the game you're on a jet
fighter you're you're fighting for a
city by riding it through getting
attacked by angels and
moment you're like on top of a mountain
while this giant snake thing comes
through the air and then you're on it
back and then you're flying through the
air and trying to hit it with a sword
and then you go to the gates of hell and
just oh my god it just it starts it
starts high right and then it just goes
it just keeps going and going and going
when you just think you can't possibly
get any more crazy and over the top of
fun it does and to me that just a
brilliant thing so congrats the Platinum
Games are making their game and if you
haven't got a wii u and you haven't
played bayonetta to go and do it it's so
good so i've had a lot of really great
fun games you see it but there is one
game which I just think is amazing and
that has to be merrier kart 8
now Mario Kart as we all know is tends
to be quite similar across different
platforms you've had the DS version the
3ds version etc but mario kart 8 man it
reminds me of it reminds me of how much
fun I had with the snares version and
the Nintendo 64 version it's just
brilliant and I think what's great about
America is when it came out I wanted to
play it and i played through it i got
the gold car i got the gold glider and
unlocked all this stuff and yet for
pretty much most of the year since it
came out we as a group in guess what UK
sat down and played Mario Cart pretty
much every lunchtime and that's just
amazing like how many other games would
you really want to keep plowing that
much time into that aren't say an MMO or
you know bigger than G is just they
managed to make a game that not only
runs at 60 frames per second all the
time it's super bright and colorful it
looks incredibly sharp it's just amazing
America 8-way just are mechanically I'm
just sorry I could carry on and just
keep talking to you about how Great
America is but it's a fantastic game
something I think everyone that has a
way you should own it again if you don't
have a wii u it's definitely worth
picking one up just to play mario kart 8